uh
women age like milk not like wine uh I
know you hate to hear that
I'm gonna give you I'm gonna give you
why I'm gonna give you why listen to me
you're drinking so much more than I
would have sex I don't care this is why
I can come to you honestly just a quick
question and I know it sounds weird but
let me land as you say do you think
lions and lionesses have a better
relationship than tigers and tigresses
do you know the difference of those
relationships because what you're
describing is a lioness who's not equal
to a lion right but what you want and
what you say and you want is to be a
tigress who's equal to a tiger tigresses
and tigers don't act anyway close to
lines and lightnesses you want that Lion
in your house but you also want to be
the lion that's not how that works no
right I want a man that fulfills a role
that I am not going to fulfill that's a
line in line
of things and let me tell you about it
I'm a tigress anyway but okay but what
you just said is opposite
house a lioness is not equal to a male
lion that's just a fact I'm not gonna
argue with nobody about it there's
Discovery Channel for you there it's
it's Wikipedia there that's equal a
Tigris and a tiger are very much so
equal equals both 500 pounds both can
bench a ton both hunt and live on their
own they come together to mate equally
have their own territory and when they
[ __ ] with each other anybody can get
them hands that's it it don't matter
who's nobody's stronger than the other
they're quite equal a lion
in a lioness
are very different you what you're
describing what you're saying is you
want a man to go and do the things that
you cannot do that's a lion
you want to be a lioness but with all
the benefits of also being the lion that
don't work nowhere in the world and I'ma
just tell you why it don't work and it's
not a disrespect I'm gonna tell you why
it don't work
it's unnatural and I'm not saying that
women are not equal to men because I
just said tigrises are equal to Tigers
I'm not saying women are not equal to
men because a black widow female kills
the male for food I'm not saying that
that can't be a possibility what I'm
explaining to you is everything that you
said
that I've been listening to I ain't
talking in like 20 minutes I went to pee
I sat down to pee because I got bad
bladder everything that I've said
everything that you said I just listened
to you talk I listen I didn't interrupt
you I didn't hear nobody else interrupt
you you was going off
you have contradicted yourself about
three or four times hold on and they've
tried to tell you that you contradict
yourself and I'm not saying this in any
other way because you want to be right
baby the problem
finished
that's what I'm saying this is what I
mean and you said you single I know
because you ain't shut the [ __ ] up okay
[Music]
you can't tell me why because if I'm
einsteiner I say E equals and you say I
don't think E equals I didn't say m c
squared yet so you don't know what the
hell I'm talking about so let me finish
what I'm saying I understand what you
want
I get what you want
I know what you want but what you want
and what you've said are two different
things and I think he's tried to explain
it I think Auntie's tried to explain it
I even think the young woman who's on
your side here tried to explain it Pearl
tried to explain it they he ain't even
saying nothing no more
I don't know what I'm saying because
you're not psychic that's the problem
that what you're having you're basically
trying to tell me that um
contradict yourself I'm saying what you
want is different than what you've said
and the problem that you're having is
not that you're not that you're
contradicting so everybody contradicts I
contradict myself all the time ask my
baby mama I can't judge himself 24 7.
what you're having the issue that you're
having is that you're struggling with
what Pearl said she hit a nerve she said
you're not young anymore
and you're arguing with her about and
she's right I hate to tell you somebody
said earlier there's 18 year olds born
every day you ain't 18. what you're
arguing with is that you want a man like
you said your words you want a man to do
be better at certain things than you are
that's a lion a lioness is better at
hunting a male lion is better at killing
hyena but in your mind you see yourself
as a tigress you just haven't joined
those thoughts you have to pick what you
want to be you have to pick what you how
you want to present yourself to the rest
of the world and what you want to do you
haven't done that what you've done is
you've gone you just asked this boy I
like you what when were you born that's
not a question okay
no no no you've gotten a lot of mic time
no let them go
to me
I'm gonna let you go bro because my last
point is literally this what you want in
life
you've told us what you want what you
see in a man what you want out of a man
what you think about abortion what you
think about all these topics everything
you've said but
that's what you want right that's what
you want but what you've said is the
opposite of what you want how you behave
is the opposite of what you want so you
have to figure out on your own this is
on your own time this is a piece for you
to take home with you you got to figure
out how to take what you want
and what you say you want and make them
the same thing and that's why I said
cooperation earlier because you cannot
that's comprom what you're trying to do
is compromise with yourself that's never
going to work you've got to cooperate
with yourself and figure it out now I
know you want to talk I know I see it
you can't there's not many things that
men can add to my life that's why
over there here's how you play a
feminist right so you get this guy she's
at the bar she's a feminist she's
talking all this stuff she thinks she's
she's kind of she's kind of arrogant
right she needs to go yeah she thinks
she's getting a female so what you do is
you don't disagree because feminists are
extremely arrogant so she's gonna
convince herself that she can change you
over the couple of days right you pipe
it for a couple weeks four weeks I'd
recommend and then you just bounce
that's how you play the feminist so as I
said at the start the Modern Woman
destroys what she loves if she likes you
you get on you smashed whatever the
first thing she's going to try and do is
diminish you she's gonna try to make you
less how she's gonna do this she's gonna
be like you should be more emotional you
should actually tell me how you feel
learn damn well that that's not why
she's attracted to you that's not why
you're there she's going to tell you all
these other things
um so that's how you play the feminist
just saying okay thanks okay so
um I'm gonna close out the show because
it's getting late uh thank you guys for
all coming why why don't we go around
everyone tell the people where they can
find you and any final thoughts that you
have
okay starting starting with you oh all
right great show man find me a bigger B
TV on all platforms YouTube Instagram
Facebook and all that good stuff and
final thoughts is just do you just do
you okay
um big tease though on Twitter
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible